il bat pavillon des nations unies le
brave commandeur est un navire
humanitaire le premier a quitté la mer
noire depuis le début du conflit en
ukraine sa mission qu'on voyait des
céréales pour le programme alimentaire
mondial en afrique
ce navire transportera 23 mille tonnes
de blé aux populations dans le besoin en
occupy des gens dans une quasi famine
nous sommes ravis que ce soit le premier
à quitter ce qu'est et qu'en plus ce
soit pour une mission humanitaire
après avoir quitté pif dénis mardi le
navire a mis le cap sur la turquie pour
des contrôles il est ensuite finalement
parti pour djibouti depuis l'accord sur
les exportations en mer noire conclu le
mois dernier entre la russie l'ukraine
la turquie et l'onu une vingtaine de
navires commerciaux sont partis des
côtes du crânienne la plupart chargé de
céréales stockées pendant des mois une
bonne nouvelle pour kiev les
exportations devraient générer des
profits et permettre de mieux préparer
les prochaines mois sont
en se basant sur les requêtes que l'on
reçoit on voit que la demande augmente
nos prévisions se réaliseront d'ici deux
mois
si les corridors existe les trajets
coûte cher notamment pour les assureurs
car ces cargaisons peuvent valoir plus
de 50 millions d'euros